please to have on the on the show for
the very first time New York met Pete
Alonzo how are you Pete I bet you are I
mean what what is what is it you know
you woke up today and you're you're a
record holder and I understand there's
lots more to go not only in your career
but this season in itself but I'm
wondering if you could take a take a
moment and pause and just take in what
you have already accomplished in 2019
yeah I mean it's this year has just been
such a really special and and just wild
ride and and I I just feel like really
blessed and humbled because this has
just been exceeded all of my
expectations I mean coming into spring
training I didn't know if I was going to
be on the team the opening day or not
like I didn't know if I was going to
make the team and I just wanted to seize
every single opportunity I had and I
just wanted to play well as I could and
and and do absolutely everything I can
to to help this team win and and just be
successful and stay here in the big
leagues and then as time went on it's
like alright well I like I kept proving
to myself that I could not only be like
a big leader but I could be a good one
and as time went on that's what through
hard work and get getting the hang of
things like okay like if I keep this up
I can make something really special
happen and that's what I'm trying to do
so who was your guy growing up you grew
up in Florida right the state of Florida
yeah I grew up I grew up in Florida but
I mean I grew up in Tampa specifically
and yeah we had to raise and everything
I would watch them if they were on TV
but I mean I was just a big baseball guy
I mean I I I was guy consider myself
kind of a kind of a baseball junkie I
spent more time playing it than watching
but I mean growing up I had some I kind
of went through certain stages of my
life because or guys that I would
specific guys outwash so when I was
younger I
I loved watching Mike Piazza that that's
when I was that's back way back when
when I when I caught so I just wanted to
be a home run inning like awesome
catcher like like Mike and then as I
kind of got older and later out of my
career my main focus was on Paul Konerko
right right first baseman just absolute
absolute stud and every every once in a
while I catch myself watching 2005 White
Sox World Series highlights and all of
them tend to be Paul Konerko and then
right now I mean still one of my I mean
after Paul retired I became a huge Paul
Goldschmidt fan because he became the I
mean he became the guy he's the right
right first baseman awesome defender
gold Glover runs the base as well not
it's not only hit for power but hits for
average and he's such a complete player
in I mean for me he's the Paul
Goldsmith's the standard of what of what
a good first baseman should be so I want
to be I want to be like him well I mean
you are you are doing it right now and
the first guy you mentioned Piazza you
passed on the all-time Mets homeruns
single-season list a couple of homeruns
ago not how to be something else then I
mean for you to say that you wanted to
be Mike Piazza first and foremost and
you you are round in the basis putting
him a notch down in the Mets record book
that had to be something yeah it's to me
it's like I like every single I put it
all my effort in thought into into each
individual day like we've got the Cubs
today we're facing Hendricks so all my
preparations can be faced on the
specific pitcher and catcher combination
we got going on and I feel like that I
mean to me I'm extremely humbled but I'm
really not going to truly understand and
so like after after the year is over
because right now it's like every single
day I like I got a I got a job to do my
job is to is to try and study study
I on the mountain and try and do
whatever I can to gain an edge and beat
them tonight because I mean we got the
Cubs we're in a tight race right now for
for the wild-card and I just want to do
everything I can but I feel like that
it's really not going to truly like
settle in until like the dust is settled
after the Year Pete Alonso here on the
Rich Eisen show and I know you don't
have a vast major league career to lean
on is in terms of perspective but it
seems to me that once Stroman was
acquired and nobody else was sent out
from that pitching staff as was rumored
this team caught fire and I'm wondering
if emerging from the trade deadline
having added and not subtracted was
something that galvanized your Clubhouse
would you say that's accurate Pete
I mean we've we've always had this self
belief the entire year whether I mean
it's I mean it's kind of hard to I mean
for other people to see especially when
earlier in the year we were we weren't
where we wanted to be like right now we
have a really great opportunity in front
of us and so many people LED wrote us
off when we were 11 games under and then
word wasn't I mean yes 11 games under
people were kind of like oh yeah
whatever but then when we kind of when
we started surging and we started
playing really well I mean that was I
feel like that kind of force I feel like
that force the front office is hand
because it's like you know what these
guys believe in themselves and we
believe in them too if they have this
self belief and drive to pull it
together and keep grinding it out then
you know what we're going to follow suit
so it's this it's the same mental added
positive mental attitude we've had all
year it's been difficult for sure
especially like earlier in the year to
keep that but I mean all of us in the
clubhouse have been extremely persistent
in our work we've all the guys have I
mean it's just I feel like the way that
we've come back and answered the bell so
far that's just in the attributes
kind of all the character all the
character in the in the clubhouse from
from all the guys I mean that's coming
back from that whole we're in I mean
that's that's really tough to do and
obviously there's still work to be done
but I think that I mean that shows a lot
of heart a lot of character from from
everybody in the clubhouse so I mean
it's it's been it's been awesome so far
how'd you get the nickname polar bear
feat Alonso don't you get that nickname
Todd Frazier that's this year that's not
that's not a lifetime thing that's
that's a this year think no yeah so
college in college I was Pistol Pete
high school sweet Pete and then and then
this year Todd Frazier spring trainings
that you look like first you call me
like Paul after Paul Bunyan
okay he's a you look like a lumberjack
or whatever and then and then he's your
site and then he came up with polar bear
he's like salsa you know you look more
like a Big Damn polar bear than anything
I'm like alright I'll take ya and then
it's stuck and it certainly as it suited
you do you feel the the hopes and wishes
and prayers of every met fan on on every
four corner of this earth in you Pete do
you feel that I mean the way that the
fans have responded and welcomed me it's
just been I mean it's been so awesome I
mean it's it's been like how well I've
been received is just extremely special
to me I mean it the way that this city
it's not just the fans like like I mean
it's it's like this this entire city has
just kind of welcomed me with open arms
and I'm just so appreciative of that and
I mean that's that's what I mean this is
what like I've dreamt of my entire life
and this is what I've worked for my
entire life and for it to kind of pan
out it's it's been nuts because that
justifies the hard work and sacrifice
that I'm pretty much not just me but my
family and everyone like a lot of people
in my life has has made
so this is I mean it's been all worth it
and it just feels so good and like I'm
forever thankful for all the all the
fans and in the support I've had
throughout New York too so it's just
been so so amazing I'm just so gracious
gracious and grateful for it and Inc
that includes the first fan Jerry Wright
Seinfeld
he loves you man Seinfeld yeah no I I
mean my dad was obviously a huge
Seinfeld fan I mean I feel like any like
any any kid that grew up in the that was
a 90s baby third their parents were huge
Seinfeld fans so it was nuts because
it's like I grew up my dad made me watch
some Seinfeld and and it's like I it's
like wow a guy that like my dad like
made me watch as a kid that was like a
huge like he's a huge mogul not just
like in the comedy world but in New York
and world renown Jerry Seinfeld as a fan
of P Alonso that's that's like what this
is so weird
it's weird to me to think about you know
it's like I just I just feel like I'm a
like I I mean I know what I say this
like people kind of scratch their head
but I still feel like a kid you know I
know I'm 24 but I mean I still feel like
a big kid well Pete it's real and it's
spectacular there's no question about
that
it is real and spectacular when it comes
to when it comes to Jerry do you have
your favorite Seinfeld episode yeah the
one where I think it's I think George
Costanza he's the he's working for the
Yankees and then I think Bernie him and
Bernie Williams are in her and Derek
Jeter are on the field and George's
absolute walkin balls and he's just like
yeah it's all about angles geometry and
a little bit of calculus it's like XY
and he's like explaining each explaining
so formal and he's whacking balls all
over the yard and they're just like who
is this guy and then he's good he's
absolutely he's hitting missiles
everywhere
I think it's because he was abstaining
at the time Pete that's that's that
that's that episode well at least you
have you haven't had anybody tell you
that go hit three home runs in the game
or something like that right not that
that was a great Paul O'Neill episode
was that one with a man also it's kind
of funny when when Elaine was like
dating Keith Hernandez oh please now
that that is the one of the all-time
great episodes with Keith and and Jerry
getting jealous and then that's the
second spitter that would also include
you know Roger McDowell of Mets Fame as
well back in the day yeah forget Kramer
Hughes he bought there's this other
episode where like Kramer bought like
this industrial he's pissed off at a
showerhead and he's got this in does
like this like this industrial like
showerhead used to shower elephants on
the black market somehow and not some of
this we're talking 25 years old there
older than you P man it's I am just I'm
excited for you Pete you know my
brother's a die-hard met fan we got our
social medias are as we like to call him
TJ Jefferson big-time met fan it's tons
of a mount in Los Angeles and you have
you've really ignited I'm excited I'm
and and good luck against the Cubs it's
a game obviously you guys need to have
and you know we'll chat soon
thank you no thank you guys so much for
having me on
I I really enjoyed my time on here so
thank you you got a t thanks again we'll
chat soon we will definitely chat soon
that's Pete Alonzo Pete underscore
Alonzo 20 on Twitter and then his old
Instagram his old nickname at pistol
underscore Pete 24 more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app